[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I have to see this
[Music]
Oh
this is gonna be awesome ready pg-13 I'm
have to ask you to turn off your cell
phone Oh Alamo Drafthouse my name is
Jeff Goldblum I'm an actor and not many
people know ain't noted if I'm a
business consultant yes that's true
so when Alamo Drafthouse asked me to
help them do something about people
talking and texting during the movies I
said hey guys have you heard of a little
picture called Jurassic Park mr. Steven
Spielberg from 93 and they said yes we
have seen Jurassic Park and so then I
said let me make some calls that cap to
let me introduce you to Sheila Alamo
Drafthouse is new anti texting and anti
talking Velociraptor you know talking
and texting during the movie that's a
no-no now maybe you're saying to
yourself or at me hey Jeff
the safe is practical to the Alamo
Drafthouse do this just because they can
here's my answer that's not my problem
[Music]
and cut
[Music]
hi Cinemark fans I'm Bryce Dallas Howard
I'm Chris Pratt do you remember the
first time you saw a dinosaur on the big
screen we want you to experience that
sense of awe and wonder again this
summer join us as we return to the
island to save the dinosaurs in Jurassic
world fallen Kingdom get your tickets in
Cinemark XD now for the ultimate movie
experience
you